قد لا يدعو البيت الأبيض
الأمريكيين إلى ارتداء أقنعة كحماية
ضد فيروس كورونا ،
لكن البحرية الأمريكية لا تأخذ أي
فرصة
على كل فرد على متنها أن يرتدي
قناعًا ،
هذه هي كلمات الأدميرال
جورج ويكوف قائد مجموعة حاملة الطائرات
الهجومية.
خمس
مجموعات ضاربة لحاملات الطائرات الأمريكية
اللتين أجرتا تدريبات بحرية مشتركة نادرة
معًا
في المياه المتنازع عليها لبحر جنوب
الصين.
تدابير
استثنائية لحماية أكثر من 12000 طيار
وبحار من خطر
فيروس كورونا ، وتشمل تلك التدابير
التباعد الاجتماعي بين
أوقات الوجبات
ودعوة المتخصصين على متن سفنهم
بما في ذلك علماء الأحياء الدقيقة ، يقول
قائد إحدى هذه المجموعات الضاربة
إن مجموعته لديها  كان مطمعا خاليا
منذ أوائل
أبريل ، والبحرية تعرف خطر
فيروس كورونا
مباشرة ال  كان هناك تفشي
أدى إلى إصابة حاملة طائرات أخرى بالشلل ، وهي الولايات المتحدة
ثيودور روزفلت ،
في الربيع ، مما أجبرها على الإخلاء الجزئي
إلى جزيرة غوام الأمريكية في نهاية المطاف
، حيث ثبتت إصابة أكثر من ألف
من أفرادها
بالمرض ،
والآن أصبحت المجموعتان الضاربتان لحاملة الطائرات
في  بحر الصين الجنوبي
جزئيًا لإرسال رسالة إلى الصين
تدعي فعليًا أن
كل هذا الجسم المائي الذي تم تهريبه بشدة
لنفسها
وأيضًا لإثبات أن البحرية
لا تزال
تعمل على الرغم
من التفشي السابق لفيروس كورونا من داخل صفوفها
إيفان واتسون cnn hong kong